this is slave 1
it's a upper-body human range of motion
and human speed robot it's not capable
of lifting things it's mainly a gestural
performance robot what's unique about it
is that all the mechanical and
electronic components are off the figure
there are 21 different motors these are
called servos radio control car servos
and each one controls one of the
movements up on the structure each of
these is controlled by a microcontroller
that's ultimately controlled by a
computer the movement of each one of
these servos is transmitted up through a
stainless steel cable up through the
middle of the robot out to the joint
that it's finally controlling so the key
technologically to this type of robot I
call a Reeve Ector block it's the red
parts and there are several in here and
they take a bundle of cables coming for
one direction and then distribute it out
into the directions that they need to go
so for example the one that's underneath
here is taking this cone of cables
coming from the motors and then grouping
them into a really tight bundle that
goes up through the middle of the torso
also the the cables have to go through
the hinge joints of the shoulder and
elbow so that's another custom-made
system to carry the the cables without
varying the path length as they flex
it's an arrangement of teflon tubes and
stiffener cables embedded in it in a
silicone rubber block that's the white
parts so the the hands on slave 0 and
slave 1 were the most complicated part
the original prototype for the fingers
was worked out using Lego technics and
some monofilament thread and this is the
prototype of the finger which has joint
sharing between the three
segments and then four of those are
attached to each of the palms on the two
robots gets a good range of gesture with
only two motors everything is
custom-made except for the motors so all
the metal is machined on a milling
machine all the red parts are custom
castings that required special custom
molds it can be driven completely
manually from an input device or it can
oscillate different joints at different
frequencies which it's doing right now
and it can also run recorded movement
routines